alors la gauche va-t-elle profiter du
succès de la mobilisation sociale dit
hier pour en parler avec nous ce soir
jean luc mélenchon bonsoir bonsoir êtes
sénateur de l'essonne à la tête du parti
de gauche tout nouveau qui tiendra son
congrès demain d'abord un mot sur le
limogeage du préfet de la manche et du
directeur de la sécurité publique on
voit que ça suscite beaucoup de
réactions ça va c'est un peu inquiétant
parce que apparemment ce préfet et toute
son équipe n'avait commis aucune erreur
particulière ils ont réussi à la fois
faire le maintien de l'ordre et à et à
permettre aux manifestants scandent
liberté de s'exprimer donc est ce qu'on
lui reproche de ne pas avoir fait taire
les sifflets par conséquent quand le
chef de l'état prend cette décision
c'est un signal qui l'envoie à la haute
hiérarchie de l'état et il leur dit vous
devez tenir la maison quand je me trouve
et je crains que ça n'aille ça ne pousse
dans la dans une pente que puis
aujourd'hui semble assez
mauvaise un bon criminaliser l'action
syndicale on dénonce des personnes
regardez quand le président sarkozy
avait dit casse toi pauvre con attendant
au salon de l'agriculture vont rappeler
cet épisode à quelques temps après
quelqu'un avec un petit carton et lui
fait la plaisanterie jean carton et bien
cet homme est condamné mais ça se passe
à la drôle d'ambiance la gauche on
revient aux manifestations d'hier
peut-elle se refaire une santé sur le
succès de la mobilisation sociale dit
hier à la de la gauche politique vous
voulez dire oui elle a déjà un devoir
céder heureusement que les syndicats
étaient là parce que si on avait attendu
après la gauche politique on y serait
encore les syndicats se sont rassemblés
ils ont donc permis que l'on mette un
peu faim à la résignation sociale donc
je crois que le président sarkozy a
mangé son pain blanc dorénavant les gens
savent qu'ils ont la force de se
rassembler comme ils l'ont fait là et
parlons du parti de gauche maintenant où
se situe votre parti avec le parti
communiste le nouveau parti
anticapitaliste d'olivier besancenot
c'est une passerelle au milieu de tout
ça pour faire une gauche de la gauche du
ps nous essayons d'être dans un rôle de
trait d'union nous sommes modestes une
formation naissante mais oui c'est vrai
notre objectif c'est de créer un front
de gauche à l'occasion des prochaines
élections
européenne nous sommes un parti
républicain parti démocratique un front
de gauche qui inclurait le parti
communiste le npa les formations en gros
toutes celles qui ont refusé le traité
de lisbonne et sur quoi vous pouvez vous
entendre abu sur beaucoup de choses déjà
on sait déjà entendu là sur une
plate-forme en commun par rapport aux
licenciements sur l'europe elle même
nous sommes d'accord sur le rejet du
traité de lisbonne écoutez c'est une
base extrêmement large ceux qui
acceptent le traité de lisbonne se
trouve dans la situation des wii
compatible à la gauche avec la droite
bon et puis il ya ceux qui refusent ce
traité bon donc cela pourrait se
rassemblent et du coup on pourrait
passer devant et rééquilibrer la gauche
un sondage vous donne 15 % d'intentions
de vote aux européennes c'est le pari
que vous faites ce soir je me garde de
paris de cette sorte mais oui ça montre
en tout cas que il ya la possibilité si
on se rassemble d'être vraiment très
fort parce que là c'est un sondage il
n'y a pas eu un jour de campagne alors
qu'est ce que ce serait au bout de
quatre mois de campagne jean luc
mélenchon merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce soir en bref julien coupat
écroué depuis trois mois dans le cas